Stephanie Liu: Hi.
In this video, I'm going
to give you a quick overview
of what you can do
with the YouTube APIs.
First of all, we all know
what YouTube is, right?
Millions of videos uploaded
from all around the world
at your fingertips.
The YouTube APIs allow you
to integrate YouTube
into your application.
There are two main APIs:
the data API,
and the player APIs.
But before I get
into more detail,
let's talk widgets.
If you're looking
for a quick sprinkling
of YouTube on your website,
there are some pre-made widgets
for you to check out.
The AJAX Video Bar makes it easy
to add a dynamic block of videos
onto your site.
All you have to do
is copy/paste some JavaScript.
There's even a handy wizard
to help you do customizations.
Use the Video Search Control
to make this block of videos
more interactive.
We also have
the custom player available.
You can change the color
and borders to match your site,
as well as size and format.
To populate your custom player,
just select
one of your own playlists.
Now, if you decide
you want to do something
that's more complex
than what these widgets offer,
then you'll wanna use the APIs,
so let's get
into a bit more detail there.
The data API is a RESTful API
that allows you to do
a wide breadth of operations.
Searching, pulling back
user information,
uploading videos,
creating playlists,
and much more.
I'll go over the two
most popular use cases,
search and upload,
and show you some examples.
First up, search.
I'm sure you've all searched
for your favorite video
on YouTube.com.
Using the API,
you can send a query
for a search term
like you would on the site,
and retrieve a few results
in XML, which you could then
display in your application
how you want.
For example, TimeTube has an
innovative viewing experience.
They take video search results
and display them on a timeline
with weighted importance.
In this web-based
presentation creator,
you can search
for videos within the app,
and then embed them
right into your presentation.
Another big operation is upload.
Your users can upload
their videos to YouTube
through your application.
For example, Animoto.com
is a slide show creation site.
Once their users
create a slide show,
they have an option
to export to YouTube.
They use the API to authorize
the user to the YouTube account,
and then send the video over.
"Spore" is a computer game
that lets you
create your own creatures.
And all proud parents
want to videotape
and share their creations,
so there's a "record" button
that lets you upload
straight to YouTube.
I've only covered a small set
of what you can do
with the data API,
but hopefully you have
some good ideas.
You can get started
with the data API
with one of our open source
client libraries.
We have them for PHP, Java,
.NET, and Python.
They make parsing feeds
and handling authentication
much easier.
I should also point out
that while we don't have
a JavaScript client library,
we do offer JSON
as an alternative format to XML
so you can easily
parse responses with JavaScript.
Now, on to the player APIs.
The player APIs give you
control over
the YouTube-embedded player.
You can issue commands, like
"stop," "pause," and "play";
listen for events,
like air events--
or which state
the player is in--
and poll status, like how far
into the video the user is.
Here's an example
of an application
that's using the player APIs
to sync up this lecture
with the slides.
If you wanna do
even deeper customizations,
use our chromeless player.
It's just a video box
with no buttons
that you can control
with the player APIs.
You can skin the player
to match the look and feel
of your application,
much like in these examples.
For even more examples,
check out our app gallery.
And once you've built something,
show us by submitting yours.
This has only been
a quick overview,
but find all the rest
of the details
on code.google.com, and ask
your questions in our forum.